you super strain of rabies getting  faster that can be contained fetus super  violent fully searched for patient zero  [Music]  there is no truly there is no cure the  turns humans into violent predators the  communication is impossible except for  me I can't speak down language why I've  been bitten but not turned  we are hidden underground in a nuclear  silo we searched desperately for patient  zero we cannot reverse engineer a  vaccine without patient zero the music's  not affecting him at all you assume  we're all the same  something new and smart is evolving you  know anything about patient zero it's  only a matter of time  trust beyond that time is a luxury you  cannot afford  we've been breached I look sick to you I  don't think that we're the disease  really cure to get rid of the human  infection we won't continue to fight  those - what we do  I suggest you ask yourself who's winning  what can you see  [Music]  you